jack reacher i mean to get back into
that a little bit i mean that's that's a
big
you know that's tom cruise big time
movie blockbuster and then they're doing
a series how many auditions did you go
on how many times did you meet with
these producers for this role
yeah you know there's always going to be
a chip on my shoulder for this because
uh you know i'm also i'm just always
going to feel like i have something to
prove no matter how many times yeah i
just went to dinner with a lot of people
involved with the show and they were
like thanking me because it shows you
know it's not out
yet i mean i don't know when this will
air but you know when we're talking
about this right now it's not out yet
but when does it come out on amazon
february 4th so um so
it's being seen by some people media you
know industry insiders test audience and
it's like everybody loves it you know
people that have read the books people
that haven't everybody's enjoying it so
like thank you for all your hard work
and what you've done and if it if you if
you didn't work as reacher this whole
thing wouldn't work but it worked
and i you know and i think back to my my
time during the process they passed on
me the first time
and they passed on everybody their first
time you know but um
you know i've put i put a tape together
you know i was approached about this as
was probably 2 000 other guys and um
and i you know i put a tape together but
the sides that they gave us were
probably not the most conducive to an
audition because it was all about
capturing that stoic you know reacher
said nothing is something sort of
famously involved in every book reacher
said nothing and the sides were
basically reached or said nothing so
there's like an interrogation where he's
just sitting there the whole time and i
was like i don't know how to play this
but in my mind i was like i have to you
know it's gotta have some energy and so
i was channeling you know the guy from
water world who's like give me the paper
give me the paper give it a go give it a
paper he's trying to trade the paper for
the girls give me the paper give me the
paper
kevin costner's like all right don't put
the knife down
i was like trying to channel that guy
they give me the paper give me the paper
guy
in my mind i'm like listening you know
imagining this guy trying to just
generate some inner something yeah and
uh and they hated it they hated it
so they just said okay no pass no i went
to pretty you know the tape went to
produce i got a call that you know they
you know it was it was interesting they
sent it to producers and then it just
never went further and like months go by
and like you know i've been doing this a
long time you hold very loosely to this
stuff like oh love the idea that that'd
be cool and then nothing happens you're
like okay this that wasn't me that was
meant for somebody else and it was sort
of that it was just like all right i
guess meant for somebody else
and then like i don't know
four or five months after that
i get a call that like they're thinking
about
redo it you know sort of coming circling
back
um
new casting director
whole new sides they're re kind of
reimagining this process and so they
were like i was like oh i'll get a
second chance and so minnie marin who
who casts uh who casts the show she's a
phenomenal casting director
she had gone back to look at the tapes
after they reimagined how to approach
finding this guy
and looked at the tapes that had gone to
producers so like thank god they sent it
to producers that time because i never
would have been seen again um and uh
she saw you saw something she saw
something in it i think with some
adjustment you know i think with some
adjustment we could you know get this to
work
but i when i saw the new size i was like
oh this i can do
you know um and so yeah it was probably
seven or eight other auditions seven or
eight other auditions
there are so many
cooks in the kitchen in a in a good way
like not in i mean there are so many
people who have a vested interest in
delivering something
that works to the fans as they should
you know it's a lot of people taking
this very seriously and want to make
sure that they get it right and
you know some
i
i only owe
mr cruz a debt of gratitude for the
visibility that he's brought to this
role but there are people who comment on
the fact that he's not exactly the size
that reaches should be and that's a
large character in this
it's its own kind of character in this
um
bigger guy than cruz
and that's true that's true but um you
know and you know it's sufficient to say
that he he also still carried those
franchises into the hundreds of millions
of dollars without that so that's a
testament to him and his his talent and
craft right he's incredible um um but
you know a lot of fans um weren't
weren't happy and um and so you know
there's obviously probably a level of
anxiety from the executives going like
we don't want to mess this up again and
so there's a lot of that energy
coming coming at these these auditions
you know um sort of a little bit of
trepidation
and uh
it you know it it it kept going but it
was like well now we want you to
read for you know the amazon exactly the
sky dance exactly this exact that
exactly where are you going to be
along the way no not at all it was like
okay as long as this is happening as
long as this conversation is happening
like then this is still good you know
and it's just another opportunity for me
to win somebody over this is the job you
know how it is like i think as soon as
you get cynical i was there was a point
in my life where i was like very soon i
came off of comedy and uh i felt like
i mean infant you know they should be
throwing rolls at me like what i just
did on the show that nobody saw
delusions of grandeur delusions of
grinder and i was like frustrated that
like you know there weren't just like 50
film off you know
it was and you know i got very bitter
for a little bit until i had this
um
this uh
perspective shift you know um through
the loss of a role but uh
um you know so it just i was up for it i
was up for it as long as it was working
and it was you know um but it was it
took a lot of
educating um
amazon on who i you know
who i am and
and then there was also a lot of
questions about height because this is
during the pandemic so we can't do this
stuff in person and in fact they flew me
out once to to test in person and uh
and and i get to the hotel in l.a and
they're like
they're gonna have to take a blood
sample this is like before you know the
swabs that we have now and they're like
they're going to take a blood sample and
i was like blood sample
i'm like this is serious like this is
what's kind of nice world are we really
got to bleed for your craft these days
i guess that's the world and i was fine
with it i was like all right that's fine
they're like all right they're talking
to lawyers about it seeing you know how
that whole thing works and i guess
eventually they got cold feet about
taking blood to
to secure a test audition um and so i
went back and we did it over zoom
but uh you know i wasn't seeing these
people in person and that's a big part
of this you know knowing
you can feel somebody's energy and their
presence and see their size so so they
they actually had me
measure myself
on tape you know like head to toe and i
couldn't you know i couldn't do it so i
had my kids on a step stool and they're
up there like measuring
like strip down your shorts and bare
feet show us exactly where that tape is
we want to see how big you saw you
without a shirt on and all that oh yeah
yeah yeah um uh you know so there was
just it was a lot of that it was a big
process of like you were in really good
shape at this time
well i was uh
yeah i was
i walk around it like you know if i'm
not working out i run a lot and i walk
around like 205 which is like still big
for a lot of people right um
and uh
205 i think if i thought you'd be bigger
than that well i am now oh you are yeah
i'm 235. oh okay yeah i was like jesus
christ yeah that's a [ __ ] 185 of my
you know bigger than that
yeah yeah i put i put on uh i put out
about 30 pounds for this you know um
but uh
yeah i wasn't at the time you know i
wasn't that big of that but you know i
still
i'm just a large guy you know guys it's
a large man it was just
um anyway but it just uh it it it was a
process and um
and uh they were convinced that um
you know i guess i was the right guy so
there was a lot of there was a lot of
apprehension when the the executive's
producer started showing up in prep when
i was actually there because i was like
now they're going to see me in person
for the first time i hope i'm big enough
and you were yeah thank god yeah well
didn't get fired here's a serious
question yeah how honestly
how demanding
was the shoot that's a good question i
mean you filmed this entire 10 episode
series
you did 10 episodes for this amazon
series jack reacher which comes out
february 4th
the demand on your body and your mind i
mean you just talked about in your
mid-30s overcoming
you know deep depression and figuring
out you have bipolar getting on meds
getting healthier finding purpose you
book this part i guess it's the right
time because you're now on the up
what are you going through
that's a good question um
i think i think uh you know and also for
anybody watching who maybe is struggling
with a lot of that stuff bringing all
that stuff to the light can only help
you know i feel like we live in a world
where it's you know i'm trying to
destigmatize normalize these
conversations so we could just let's
just get it let's talk about it you know
talk about it
this is only it can only help to talk
about it but you know i had an assistant
on the show and she's well aware of all
of that you know and so it was like help
me
pay attention to because it's hard for
me to see
those changes you know um you know am i
am i how am i doing mentally you know
like and you know and she's like if uh
if you need to slow down like let's just
slow down at any time of course i never
said i needed to but
um but you should have
but you can't you know i mean you know
there's like you know yeah
so
the toughest thing i don't ever want to
complain
about i have nothing to complain about i
live a privilege a privileged life and
uh i've i've always
i'm living the dream that i i've worked
for you know i mean it's a dream come
true you know what i do for a living i
enjoy
um it challenges me it keeps me holds my
interest nothing else can do you know
i'm just i get bored easily i love what
i do i don't want to complain but it was
the most challenging shoot i've ever had
to endure and it just about killed me
really i did yes and i do i mean that i
mean that i'm gonna
you're gonna get some info that no no
other i've given any other media or
whatever but i'll just get into it with
you